I think so I think you're limited only
by you should say I think you create
your own limitations you know I look at
things and say whether it's a problem or
an opportunity what should it be what
can it be and then work from that
backwards and say okay this is what it
should be this is what it can be how do
I make it be those things and I think
that that's the art is an opportunity to
think big I think it's an opportunity to
you know to do things both at home and
abroad in which you can make you no
significant change I think we're you
know there are things we've been doing
in in this session of the Senate that
move us in that direction of thinking
big that no child in America should go
to sleep at night without health care
coverage Senate just passed that house
passer and fight with the president
about it but ultimately that's thinking
big that no child in America greatest
country in the world goes to sleep at
night without health care I think it's
thinking big that we could create real
quality educational opportunity for
every student America to go to college
as the ability willing to work hard and
give something back to their country I
think we just passed something that's
going to move us in that direction the
greatest amount of resources for that
effort money and since the since the GI
Bill and so I i think there's there's
opportunities to think bad just a
question of do you create your own
limitations
you